let's talk about knockout j/s the
organizational library we'll be using in
this lesson now since knockout is an
organizational library we'll get most of
the same things we've talked about
before models views and octopus but they
don't call it octopus in knockout it's
called a view model if you go to
knockout Jas comm you'll find a whole
bunch of information here including some
of these unfamiliar terms let's spend a
minute unpacking some of these terms
first we have view model the view model
is similar to the octopus that we know
and love it's the thing that connects
and separates the model from the view
the main difference for now is the name
also keep in mind that the word view
model is one word in this case so when
we say MV VM VM represents one term not
to the model of the view and the view
model next we have declarative bindings
up until now you've been connecting your
Dom elements with your data in the model
by writing code in the octopus and
probably there have been a few times
that it seemed especially tedious a lot
of the methods that we write on the
octopus end up doing the same old thing
simply passing a value this way or this
way now rather than write all of that
tedious logic in the octopus or the view
model
naca lets you connect these two using
bindings that you put in the HTML now
it's important to point out that it
still is going through the view model to
get the data we are not connecting
things directly the difference here is
that instead of writing a bunch of code
in the octopus or the view model which
goes and grabs portions of the view
we're going the opposite way we're
putting the logic in the Dom in the form
of bindings we'll get into them in more
detail in just a moment but suffice it
to say that bindings are a great way to
make the connections between the view
and the view model without writing a lot
of repetitive functions that ultimately
do the same thing manually next we have
automatic UI refresh
ui stands for user interface and
knockout will watch your model data
and automatically refresh the view when
it changes effectively that some of our
octopus code that knockout is
responsible for doing automatically and
if you set up the right declarative
bindings in your Dom knockout will
actually watch things in your view like
input boxes and automatically update the
model when view stuff changes sometimes
that's called two-way binding and lastly
we have dependency tracking sometimes
your model data depends on other model
data for example if we were to get our
clicked cats levels which increase as
the cats get more clicks the level data
right here would depend on the clicks
data knockout lets us create that
relationship where one model depends on
another and will automatically track
those dependencies for us and update
things accordingly so these four terms
are some of the important new terms that
you probably should know if you're
working with knockout Jas and in fact if
you ever pick up a new framework always
go to the website and look for these
kinds of terms that you don't already
know and figure out what they mean
usually the concepts once you think of
them in English are not very hard now in
terms of these last three they'll make
even more sense once we do it ourselves